[Music]  i'm running out of time elizabeth  the land is dying  people are suffering  soon  [Music]  they'll starve  and the machines meant to help us are  out of control  i have to find a way to fix it all and  the answer  is somewhere out in the forbidden west  in the west  [Music]  war  is the rule  peace  the exception  the rebel leader regala seeks to  slaughter  all those who've wronged her  she will kill anyone  who gets in her way  they say she answers to a higher power  he supplied her with troops  weapons  even  the ability to control machines  machines  of war  whatever secrets he has  he's keeping to himself  and the solution i need is broken and  scattered  everywhere i look  things are falling apart  i don't know if i can find a way for it  all by yourself  [Music]  no way oh be careful and we're coming  with you  [Music]  we will find the answers  but beware  we're not the only ones who seek them  [Music]  playstation